you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's program
proving the doubters wrong the prime
minister defends glasgow's climate
summit but were the promises made enough
to keep 1.5 alive after criticism of a
weakened final deal china says developed
countries should take the lead in ending
coal consumption
and president biden will meet xi jinping
later tonight he'll press for further
action from china on climate change
[Music]
hello there a very good evening after
two weeks of intense negotiations
politicians scientists and activists are
assessing the impact of cop 26 amid
criticism of a deal watered down by some
of the biggest emitters the prime
minister boris johnson has again
defended the climate summit's
achievements saying the agreement
settled on by all nations has proved the
doubt is wrong this claim was challenged
by the labour leader in the house of
commons this afternoon let's have a
listen to what they both said
we have seen some countries that really
should know better
dragging their heels about their paris
commitments
but if
not this one but if and it is still a
massive if
they make good on their pledges then i
believe that glasgow will be remembered
as the place where we secured a historic
agreement
and the world began
to turn the tide
the summit was held back by the prime
minister's guileless boosterism which
only served to embolden the big emitters
the the prime the prime minister praised
inadequate net zero plans he called the
australia plans heroic
even though their plan was so slow
that it was in line with four degrees of
global warming
by providing this cover
the prime minister had little chance of
exerting influence over the other big
emitters
and we saw many more disappointing
national plans
well joining me now to reflect on the
promises made and what effect they might
have is mary robinson chair of the
elders independent group of global
leaders great to see you we met right at
the start of uh cop two weeks on the
prime minister says it was historic and
changing sakia stama says it's a missed
opportunity where do you stand
well the elders did deplore a lack of
actual leadership
before and at cop
in understanding that we can't be on
course for a world of 2.4 degrees
celsius which we still are
but i do think a lot of progress was
made in a kind of
global messy way you know
that's the way the cop works by
consensus
for example we doubled the climate
adaptation finance which is really
important for countries
um there were a number of
side side issues that were important
like
the agreement on methane
which john kerry takes a lot of credit
for methane is dangerous in the short
term cutting it can help us
and many countries pledged to that
for the first time
we we saw agreements on coal before the
the the end point of of downgrading the
the wording in the uh final closing
decision um but
uh we saw um
investments hugely turning to going
green so all of these things will help
and we saw an urgency not in the leaders
who should have seen that urgency but
everybody else the small island states
the indigenous peoples the civil society
the young climate activists they were
the ones that kept me going kept me
lifted
i met so many of them and was so
impressed by their
determination they're not going to give
up
so i think going forward
um the cop
didn't
achieve
closing the gap probably we didn't think
it would but it kept alive the 1.5 and
that is really important kept it alive
with a big task on all communities now
it goes to local level in every country
every country has to do locally
what it takes to achieve this
transformative change which will be good
for people it will be healthier it will
be we won't have the fossil fuel the
cities will be much greener much cleaner
we'll have farms in the cities because
we live vertical farms and we'll have
gardens in the cities we'll have
you know
the regenerative agriculture all these
things that
were talked about at various side issues
in cup have to come together yeah it's
great to hear your uh positivity that is
fantastic but there was disappointment
as well wasn't there especially
in the wording of the final uh document
we know that
india pushing hard to phase down not
phase out coal what did you make of that
yeah
well it was very significant that
phasing out of coal and out of fossil
fuel subsidies was in the final document
we've never seen that before at previous
cops so that was a big step
and then
in many ways we have to understand the
different contexts of different
countries i have a lot of empathy for
india actually i i praised the
commitment they made and some people
said it's only 2070 that they're going
to commit to be out of um coal and and
net zero but actually they're a huge
country with very low per capita um uh
you know
problems um they're they're the the
emissions per capita of indians are far
far lower than europe and far far lower
than the united states so let's get real
here
um india has a huge problem
it's gone solar a lot it has very poor
population
they depend on coal if they go too fast
you'll have you know poverty of people
there are two kinds of um subsidies on
uh fossil fuel the first is the
production subsidy that's the one we
have to get rid of do you know what that
is that is
you know i can you know it's hard to
believe that is tax exemption we tax
exempt oil and gas companies stop doing
that and then there's the consumption
subsidies which is what we're talking
about where if we take those subsidies
away people won't be able to afford
maybe food
they'll be in real poverty so
you know we we have to understand and
that's what that's what that's the value
of a cop
that every side sees
every side and you saw the small island
states
very depressed about only uh you know
um
moving down on coal not moving out not
phasing out facing down not phasing out
but they also understand and that's why
we got agreement and now we have to work
forward and that's the important thing
okay um and of course uh more
commitments uh hopefully in a year's
time in egypt great to get your thoughts
every year so important exactly exactly
mary robinson thank you very much indeed
okay let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and a
yougov poll for sky news has found that
while the majority of people questioned
accept that the climate is changing
because of human activity the country is
divided on how to tackle the issue only
two in five people or 44 percent would
support an increase in taxes to help
solve climate change 44 percent oppose
that idea 59 of people supported an
increase to the cost of air travel which
39 opposed a low number of respondents
also supported increases to the cost of
gas electricity petrol diesel meters
well with most people opposing that idea
royal dutch shell has announced it is
scrapping its dual share structure and
moving its head office to britain from
the netherlands after being pushed away
by dutch taxes and climate pressure from
courts the company was recently ordered
in court to slash its carbon emissions
to protect the environment
a british environmental activist on a
mission to end plastic waste has
traveled to the headquarters of the
maker of tampax in geneva to hand back
plastic tampon applicators ella dash
made a giant applicator from 1200 which
she found littering uk beaches and
waterways she wants procter gamble to
stop using single-use plastic tampon
applicators which take hundreds of years
to decompose the company says it's
working on finding solutions
now china has responded to criticism
that it helped weaken the language on
phasing out coal at the climate summit
china says when it comes to ending coal
consumption developed countries should
take the lead and provide more support
to developing nations well the comments
all come ahead of a meeting between
president biden and china's premier xi
jinping a bit later tonight
we encourage developed countries to take
the lead to stop using coal and at the
same time we encourage developed
countries to provide adequate funding
technology and capacity building support
for the energy transition of developing
countries what we need is not only a
slogan but also concrete action
let's go straight to washington dc join
our correspondent joe pike so joe can
president joe biden expect to get
anything more out of china on the
climate when the two men talk later
well he certainly jonathan has said he
will bring up the issue of the
environment at that uh bilateral meeting
that only the third time the two leaders
have met and clearly they are both very
significant actors in trying to tackle
climate change but we should also point
out relations between the two countries
are strained they are tense and whilst
the environment may be on the
agenda it will not be at the top of the
agenda or probably that close to the top
other issues we expect to be discussed
include
trade cyber security nuclear
non-proliferation
and perhaps taiwan as well and it has
been really fascinating to listen to the
sort of change in tone in previous weeks
both countries talking about their
relations and their approach the
environment in different ways certainly
at the start of cop of course joe biden
was very critical of t jinping not
turning up saying that that was a big
mistake the chinese negotiator obviously
responding by saying well
some countries of course did respond did
a pull out of
previous cops previous
climate commitments and not of course a
donald trump uh the paris accords in uh
2015
and of course yet again as you mentioned
with mary robinson uh there was that
watering down of on the issue of of of
coal
but china i do say they have done a lot
on this issue some of course would um
would maybe uh critique that we've also
heard today from john kerry he's been
visiting paris and he is the us's
climate envoy this is what he said an
optimistic message i think from john
kerry in relation to the relations
between the two uh countries over
climate in the agreement we forged with
china he said this is a surprise
agreement between the two countries in
the final days of cop which no one
believed was possible even in the midst
of the conflict we have over other
issues we did negotiate an agreement
where china specifically agreed that
they will next year before cop 27 in
egypt submit an ambitious national
action plan to deal with methane but as
we saw in that clip from the chinese
government jonathan the chinese believe
that
that developed countries need to play
their part as well
okay joe in washington for us thank you
very much indeed for that do stay with
us coming up after this short break i'll
be joined by author and presenter
ziatong and tom river carnac co-founder
of global optimism a climate podcaster
and an author as well we'll be speaking
to them in a moment discussing all the
fallout from cop 26 of course and if
it's time to change the way climate
negotiations are done we'll see you in a
minute
hello again welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day with author
and presenter ziatong and tom river
carmack co-founder of global optimism he
was also chief political strategist at
the un climate change convention for the
paris agreement back in
2015 with the glasgow climate pact as
it's now been called has of course
provoked differing reactions as we've
been hearing progress certainly but
limited great to see you both thanks for
being with us tom perhaps we can uh
start with you as i was saying you were
heavily involved in creating the paris
agreement uh in 2015. do you think that
glasgow climate pact has moved things on
significantly
well it's definitely move things on i
mean significantly is the difficult part
of your question there but i would argue
that it has paris set him in motion a
process that would decarbonize the
economy over multiple decades with these
really important waypoints where
countries come back to the table and
they make renewed commitments to keep us
in line with our ultimate objective of
staying within 1.5 degrees now what we
saw in glasgow was a big step forward at
paris we may have been committed to 1.5
but we were heading for more than four
out coming out of glasgow if you add up
the national commitments it's 2.4
degrees if you look at some of the
pledges it could be as little as 1.8 now
that's clearly not enough and it needs
to go further and faster but it did take
us a long way towards where we need to
go and when combined with the agreement
that countries will come back to the
table in 12 months time with new
commitments
i think 1.5 is still very much on the
table
yeah um what do you make of that zaya
i mean we're still a long way off from
1.5 but in a year's time we'll be
discussing it all again we'll be forcing
those countries won't we that aren't
doing enough to really look at
themselves
well i think that when you have the
president al-aqsharma of cop actually
reduced to tears at the end of the
conference and saying that it's a deep
disappointment it's very difficult to
claim that this is a success by any
measure especially because the un
actually had three criteria for success
one that we would actually see a 50
percent reduction in co2 by 2030 second
that we would see the 100 billion
dollars in payment from rich to poor
countries and third that 50 percent of
that would go toward adaptation all
three criteria were not met so i think
you can dance around the margins and
pretend that this was a success but in
truth it wasn't
well tom that's pretty damning isn't it
what what do you make of that
well i can understand precisely what
she's saying i mean this is
disappointing right we need to go
further and faster but i would just say
within the confines of multilateralism
which is incredibly difficult very
frustrating nobody gets what they want
at the end of the day these things are
always disappointing when we were
putting the paris deal together we
jokingly used to say that the thing we
were aiming for was for everybody to be
equally disappointed now at the end of
the day what we've come out of here is a
hard one
agreement out of glasgow i would argue
that with the commitments in place with
the additional step up that gives us a
pathway to get to where we want to be
does it guarantee we'll deliver it
absolutely not is there is the
possibility of failure still on the
table of course it's still there do
china and india and every other country
need to step up further and go further
yes absolutely they do but what we've
seen i would say is some elements of
this agreement that are significant i
mean we're now talking about 1.5 as a
threshold we're now talking about
renewed finance for adaptation new
commitments from national countries some
transformative commitments on forests
and methane and coal
some of those have gaps in them and of
course you can chuck rocks is it enough
absolutely not will i take it as a step
in a process that unfolds over multiple
years to get us to where we need to go
that's inevitably going to be slower
than we would want to
i would say actually it does take us
forward okay as i let's talk about some
of those things then um some of the the
the more positive things that came out
of of glasgow tom mentioned
deforestation there uh for example more
than a hundred countries have pledged
pledged to end deforestation by 2030. a
similar pledge was made in 2014 of
course nothing came of that surely this
time something really can fundamentally
happen
well i want to start by saying that i
don't want to come across as doom and
gloom i am typically doom and bloom
but i do want to say that this new york
deforestation pledge that came out uh
seven years ago what did it result in
well there was a 2019 study that
actually looked at the results and it
found that ever since that pledge we've
seen a 41
increase in deforestation our
deforestation rates have increased to
the equivalent of one united kingdom
every single year so pledges are not
performance and when we look at kovid
for instance we started seeing that
people were wearing masks restaurants
change their hours or their opening
behaviors or what have you things
physically change if we're actually
looking at deforestation we would need
to see robust measures for example
whether it is let's say publishing
companies not using trees instead using
ebooks instead of using toilet paper
people starting to use bidets instead of
for example the old growth forest being
logged in places like british columbia
instead of using bioenergy and forest
for fuel all of these things would
actually change and they would be on the
table if we were having a real
discussion another thing that's really
critical to keep in mind is in these
discussions of language that we've been
having they're incredibly incredibly
weak i wanted to picture for example if
we had had 26 years of conferences on
lung cancer and we were not able to use
the word cigarette that is exactly what
is happening here 26 years of cough and
we cannot use the words oil and gas
something is very wrong here i would use
the f word and the f word is feckless
okay it's a good word i wonder what word
you were going to use then but feckless
i will take
tom i i suppose i suppose one of the
issues here is that really if we're
going to if we're going to do this we're
going to do it quickly enough we need
systemic change we need a huge amount of
effort from everybody right around the
world and we've done a a poll today
which says that 40 percent of uk people
support raising taxes to reduce carbon
emissions only 40 percent now that's not
going to be enough is it it's down to
you it's down to me to to make changes
surely in order to reach these
commitments otherwise cop 26 just does
become a talking shop
well i i thought that was a very
interesting statistic when you guys put
it out that 40 would support raising
taxes i mean i agree that that's an
interesting number i wonder how you ask
that question is going to lead to a
different outcome i think actually what
we need to do is shift the tax base so
that we stop taxing things that we want
in our economy you know like employment
and we stop taxing things um that we
don't want like pollution and actually
that shifting can be revenue neutral so
i think there's a lot in how you ask the
question but the the core of what you
described there is actually that we need
systemic change now let's just go back
to the previous point you made because
it's a really great example in 2014 a
group of countries came together and
made this new york declaration on forest
that everybody was very enthusiastic
about but the truth is it was kind of
thin right it was a statement from
countries there was no implementation
plan and so as a result inevitably in
glasgow when us when a similar looking
type of commitment comes out everybody
says you know this is meaningless you
said this seven years ago you didn't do
it it went up by 41
how come you're lying but actually if
you dig under the skin of this
commitment not only is it 100 countries
committing to reversing deforestation by
2030 it's also real money on the table
to the tune of 20 billion i'm so sorry
we are out of time but it's been great
listening to your thoughts tom rivett
karnick and xiatong thank you both very
much